hey buddy you look sad
shouldn't you be working well I was just
thinking about this year you know it's
the dizzying highs the sludge filled
lows oh and that time I was in jail it's
not been a bad year I'm not mad I'm just
disappointed yeah my mom used to say
that like if she caught you drinking no
just about me every morning at breakfast
Wow
although that kind of reminds me of some
of the video games this year
how is my childhood like video games let
me explain sir and exactly 120 seconds
the show is definitely called in two
minutes so there I was bare ass in jail
roll intro please even if you ignored
the absurd and often hilarious face
glitches on PC you were funny yes
ignoring those Assassin's Creed unity
was just a bit of a letdown for me I
mean Paris ah Paris was great intricate
beautiful mostly on fire the older joy
it got from that was tarnished by the
shoddy performance any time there was a
huge crowd on screen or a really
important moment in the game
the framerate would just plummet also
after being let loose on the high seas
as a swashbuckling rock star pirate last
time around I didn't want to be confined
to a closed-off City again I felt like a
lion released into the wild
and then recaptured like that time you
freed that lion yes it ate my clothes
and I ended up in jail let me stop you
there because I got the same vibe from
destiny now don't get me wrong I think
destiny is great and the performance was
solid but my god after travelling over
the same location time and time again to
have dinklebot decode some thing that
was amazing it just got tired without
friends to play with it's drier than a
dust sandwich you've got to stop eating
those but it never really looked good
for a thief with bumpy development the
game exchanging hands many times and the
final result just felt underwhelming and
uninspired it looked nice and the
weapons were a blast but why would you
choose to play it when dishonored a game
released two years ago did everything
thief tried better NHL 15 attempted new
heights in disappointment
the last game missed the next-gen boats
while they worked on debuting hockey to
the new consoles this year
all that time and they managed to lose
game modes from the 2013 edition it
could certainly hold its head up in
graphical prowess and presentation it's
just too bad there wasn't more game in
their game did you say train no I said
because I blame the hype train for the
disappointment of watchdogs Chicago was
cool and it was a good game but we were
promised the world a hackable City at
our fingertips and in reality what we
got was more of a bollard raising
simulator it did have some killer
missions but more than anything what we
need to learn from watchdogs is not to
buy into the hype ultimately it's just
not fair in the game I blame my own
personal height for the sadness I feel
over the Elder Scrolls online now I love
Skyrim never heard of it it wasn't
enough Elder Scrolls to come close to
that and it wasn't a good enough MMO to
come close to Warcraft it had some
impressive landscapes and reasonable PvP
but none of it quenched my insatiable
RPG thirst thirsty huh
try being thirsty in jail and I rode
that lion bare-assed across the border
and to freedom
that's the story of The Lion the Witch
and the Wardrobe that's no way to
address a king anyway that's it for
today this year in fact yes in two
minutes we'll return in January complete
with regular host Lucy James for more
gaming mysteries solved in two minutes
in two minutes on GameSpot calm we'll
see you next year also on YouTube